I have this reoccurring dream I feel the
warmth let the Sun on my skin and the
comfort of arms around me and I want to
stay there forever but that would be
impossible I have a severe sensitivity
to sunlight doctor appts became a part
of my routine it's not gonna fall into
remission and every year the risk
becomes more serious so I spend all my
time indoors behind special windows
sleeping during the day and staying up
all night and playing music every chance
I get
what should I have said hey I'm Katie
Price I've watched outside my window for
the past 10 years and I've been in love
with you stalking you every minute this
is what Taylor Swift does she has
awkward interactions with boys and then
she just writes amazing songs father I
don't understand how we've never met
I've probably skated by your house every
day on the wid practice hey you wouldn't
want to do something sometime would you
I'm really busy during the day but I
like to be free at night
what does Katie price want to do there's
so many things I want to do he's taking
me in first live show that was literally
one of the best things that are right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I am not comfortable with him not
knowing I'm going to I just need a
little longer being someone more than
just a disease this isn't something you
can just not tell me I'm so sorry but
we're not the couple who doesn't try
[Music]
I'm looking at my whole life to feel
[Music]